I think it was our first to our second
shoot we were in Amsterdam and I did a
video called existential bummer which I
think fundamentally is to be honest the
the worm at the core the faint disquiet
that haunts our dreams and existential
bummer was inspired by the work of
Ernest Becker Ernest Becker wrote a
Pulitzer Prize winning book called the
denial of death in 1974 and this book
was a distillation of the human
condition as he saw it he was a cycle
psychologist and it kind of built on the
Freudian idea that our neurosis and our
anxiety stems from us being like
sexually repressed and Ernest Becker's
ideas was idea was that no our anxiety
in our existential conundrum is not only
that we're sexually repressed but it's
that we're repressing the most
fundamental horror of all which is that
we are mortal beings mortal beings who
dream of immortality
I remember this professor called Sheldon
Solomon who was featured in a
documentary called flight from death
that put it quite succeed Lee he said
the explicit awareness that you're
breathing piece of defecating meat
destined to die and ultimately no more
significant than the lizard or potato is
not especially uplifting this was this
was the worm at the core it's like no
matter what our aspirations no matter
what our dreams no matter how intense
our love affairs how highs our ecstasy's
like everything was sort of tinged by
this anxiety about ephemerality about
transience and so existential bummer was
an exploration of that tension of that
disjoint 'men right it was like well
here are these cosmic beings that can
dream about the infinite right that can
ponder the infinite you know yet we're
housed in heart pumping breasts gasping
decaying bodies I mean it's like oh [ __ ]
that's where existential bummer came
from for me and it's a very personal
video and I think it resonated with a
lot of people because I think it may be
maybe it gave voice to something that we
all have felt but hadn't quite
articulated
you know it's like when it's you know
you turn 20 years old or 25 years old
it's your birthday you're supposed to be
celebrating but you start to get like
this kind of sadness about the fact that
it's another birthday and another trip
around the Sun and you know and or that
feeling you get when you stare at old
photographs right those sepia-toned
photographs the aging photographs it's
what makes filters on Instagram so
poignant to make something vintage to
age it increases its poignancy because
it reminds you that the moment has
passed but it was a transitory enchanted
moment that is no more and this like for
me it's just like it's annoying anxiety
and I and I think that whether we're
aware of it or not I think it's the worm
at the core for a lot of our mental
distress and I think existential bummer
gave gave voice to that